visca pleasantly rewards Nobel Prizes
shimmy welcome to this press conference
where we will present this year's Nobel
Prize in Chemistry
we will keep toad tradition and start in
Swedish and then continue in English and
in the question session you may of
course use either language
yo yeah here the staff Annunaki extended
security rather he'll become Elliot and
scoffs Academy the Hager may see the
professor's friendly D smooth for the
Nobel Committee and Fushimi photo
bernstrom a professor moans embarrass my
leader moot a Nobel Committee on for
physique
oh let's please Haram he'll microscope
in live Dylan no no Scotty come Liga he
attends cops Academy in Havasu that if
they'll add photos and filter notion of
L please see me till dr. Eric Betsey
with Howard Hughes Medical Institute
Ashburn you saw professor Stephan hell
with Max Planck Institute for
geophysical shake kami göttingen of
Deutsche scripts for Zhang centrum
Heidelberg Jerusalem or professor
William Werner
with Stanford University Stanford River
Song Academy is motivating leader for
youth Reckling of super abreast
fluorescence microscopy this year's
price is about how the optical
microscope became an honest cope the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences has
decided to award the 2014 Nobel Prize in
Chemistry to dr. Erik bet sig and how do
you smelly Institute a spawn you say
professor Stefan hell at Max Planck
Institute for by physical chemistry
göttingen and the German Cancer Research
Center Heidelberg Germany and professor
William learner at Stanford University
stands
you will say for the development of
super resolved fluorescence microscopy
professor smelly Dean will now give us a
short summary please
Thank You Stefan now this is could
someone please do something about the
resolution that's a question that
microscopists have asked for many years
ever since the invention of the
microscope this has been the challenge
we see new things but we see that there
are more things to see in 1873 and
zarbor proved that the theoretical limit
to resolution is about half the
wavelength of the light used for visible
light that translates to about 200
nanometers now the single human hair is
about 100 micrometers that's 500 times
larger than this limit so objects of
that size are very easily studied with
conventional microscopy but most of the
processes in chemistry and biochemistry
take place at length scales that are
much smaller
a typical bacterium is about 200
nanometers across corresponding to the
abbe elimin which means that if we study
bacteria in the light microscope they
will be featureless blobs just like our
laureates right now this price
celebrates the circumvention of the Abuk
condition and three scientists have
contributed to break this limit in two
different ways Stefan hell developed
stimulated emission depletion microscopy
sted and Alec Betsy and w/e Myrna laid
the foundations for single flora for
microscopy
now why is this important electron
microscopy has a much higher resolution
and can be used to study structures in
atomic resolution but election
microscopy does not allow us to study
living cells or the processes within
them the work of the laureates has made
it possible to study molecular processes
in real time it's been used to study the
dynamics of transcription and
translation that is the reading of DNA
and the transference from that to
proteins it's enabled us to look at how
proteins associated with disease
aggregate for example in Alzheimer's
Huntington's and Parkinson's disease and
he's even shown us the structural
dynamic changes to neurons in the brain
that takes place during learning
processes super-resolution microscopy
doesn't only tell us where but also when
and how and that is the greatness of
this development biology has turned to
chemistry chemistry has turned into
biology guesswork has turned into hard
facts and obscurity has turned into
clarity now could we please have that
clarity back lovely
now we can observe ecoli just like the
laureates on the screen in all the glory
of super resolution without having to
kill them slice them fixate them and
subject them to intense radiation and
high vacuums they can be studied in real
time why they live long and prosper
back to you Stefan Thank You Sven now I
turn to Professor Mon Ciaran Barry to
give a presentation so this price as you
have learnt already is about seeing and
what we have in front of us is a neuron
and nerve cell and here to the left is
the way it could be seen in the old days
before the laureates did their inventive
work and to the right we see the neuron
as it can be seen today and it's labeled
with fluorescent markers and it's this
fluorescence that makes the miracle
possible and another aspect of this
which was already mentioned is that this
is a snapshot five second snapshots you
can make a film of this and see how it
grew grows and how it moves so what the
price is about is to extend the realm
that can be addressed by light
microscopy so today or one could
traditionally look at ants with very
good results and the hair as we have
learned from our chairman of the
committee and mammalian cell can be seen
quite well but bacterial you can see a
little bit about the shape of it you can
see no internal structures human
mitochondria well you can see the shape
but nothing of its internal structures
the virus a protein and a really small
molecule all of them will look the same
in traditional traditional light
microscopy and the laureates work has
now expanded what we can do with light
max microscopy from bacteria down to
really small organic molecules the first
person that the first observation we can
make is that the diffraction limit that
family Dean was talking about makes it
impossible to focus a laser beam down to
a very very small spot so here is a
microscopy a microscope blue light and
here the yellow light is fluorescence so
the blue light excites it fluorescence
is coming from an organelle that we want
to observe and we have a broad yellow
spot and this has been well known and
one day this person then a very young
man he decided to there must be way to
break this abbis limit and make very
very small spots of laser beams so that
we can use them to explore the finest
detail of living beings and so what he
came up with in exile in Finland
actually from Germany he discovered that
if you now have your exciting blue light
you can surround it with red light so
and in this way quench the yellow
fluorescence from the focus so here you
see fluorescence and here you see the
quenching red light and if you now
increase the intensity of the red light
surrounding the fluorescence in the
middle the fluorescence intensity gets
sharper and sharper and sharper when you
really have a lot of real
right you see you can make a very very
short focus all of a sudden this had
been considered to be impossible
ever since the microscope was invented
and then when you have this short focus
what you do you let your laser beam scan
your sample with an organelle for
instance and you can scan it in x and y
and z directions in the side layer and
also in the depth and then you can make
a very very short picture of an
organelle which is now a mitochondrion
okay and here is a bacterium was the
first experiment where Stefan hell
demonstrated his principle
experimentally 1989 william moore iner
he's detected a single fluorescent
molecule that was the first time this
was done single molecule very very
difficult but he did it and then given
that you could look at single molecules
Eric Betsy he got an idea
suppose that you have a sample here an
organelle and now you shine light on it
and you get fluorescence from it then
the different fluorescing molecules here
they will appear like big blobs
according to this abbis diffraction
limit but if you know that the molecules
are so separate from each other that on
your detector you only see light from
single separated molecules you can
determine their position with very high
precision but then the problem is if you
want to label an organelle and get a
high-resolution structure you need to
have very very dense labeling otherwise
there are big holes which you didn't
label and you didn't see yeah because
you see through the power of
fluorescence so it's idea of
let's label them with green labels
yellow labels and red labels and then
that the microscope only see the green
labels they are separate from each other
so then you can determine their
positions with high precision the yellow
ones are also separate from each other
you can determine their position and the
red ones the same and if you put all
these pictures together you can get a
reasonable reasonably well labeled
organelle however what you really want
to have is this and for this you may
need like thousands of colors that can
be separated by the microscope and so
this didn't work practically although it
was a brilliant idea so then one day
William Berner discovered a
photoactivatable protein a green
fluorescent protein and we see it here
it looks like a can of beer and if you
shine light 488 nanometers on it it
blinks 10 times as you noted maybe and
then it it's turned off so nothing
happens however much light you should
shine on it nothing happens but then if
you shine another type of light with 405
nanometer wavelength and then we start
to sign the 488 nanometers it blinks
again so it has been activated it was
turned off and it could be activated and
from this this type of proteins they
started to be become developed and then
Eric bet sig got a solution to his
problem and so if you now have a green
fluorescent protein here all
them or quenched turned off and then you
send in a pulse and you activate say one
per mill of them and then all these are
now separate from each other so that you
can determine their positions very very
well and then you run them until they
are bleached out and disappear
irreversibly and then you activate
another fraction and you determine its
positions and then another fraction and
another fraction and another fraction
all these small fractions and you run
them out and then in the end you have a
whole stack of pictures and you put them
together and you get a beautiful
mitochondrion with fantastic resolution
and that was the the intimate work
between Eric Beth sig and William burner
they didn't work together but they could
do these things in a way together and so
here is a result from bed six first
application of his method called pal so
here is say what's in an organelle
called lysosome
and here is what you see when you have
diffraction limited resolution and this
is what bed six method gave you see and
then this one is expanded and here is
the Arbus diffraction limit and you will
see you can see the single proteins here
is a fantastic improvement and so from
this considerations we have awarded the
Nobel Prize to these three persons Eric
Betsy Stefan W hell and W e Myrna thank
you very much professor remember we're
not trying to get hold of professor
Stefan hell and I think we have him a
line from a phone in
Germany good day professor hell thank
you so professor hell and I'm sitting
here in the session hall at the road
Swedish Academy of Sciences and we have
a number of journalists from all over
the world that are here and I think some
of them are eager to ask some questions
and and here comes the first one to
finish a congratulations
this is Swedish television SVT your live
our live broadcast could you something
has already been said about your work
could you describe the significance of
it in your own words please yeah I mean
in Part B is very important to the life
sciences because the use of focused
light is the only way that allows you to
see living things however the resolution
of light microscopy was fundamentally
limited about a fifth of a thousand
family made admitted and if you want to
see a protein distributions at much
higher resolution at much smaller scale
it's simply impossible and definitely
not in in lifestyle
now what we have found is that you can
overcome this limit you can see details
at much much higher spatial resolution
and this of course discloses how the
cell works at the nanometer scale so
that's at a molecular scale at a macro
molecular scale and it's of course very
very important to a understanding how
the cell works and be understanding what
goes wrong if the cell is somehow
diseased do something disease that's you
know something so it's very important
for understanding the physiology at a
level and of course understanding
disease a terrible level if I may
continue could you say something about
how you got the idea why I came across
this this diffraction problem is what
did I
during my pieces on like a schematic or
confocal microscopy method but not for
the life science is not sort of
fluorescence he was basically for
microstructure inspection I got bored
with the topic so I felt this is kind of
19th century physics and I was wondering
whether there's still something profound
that could be made with light microscopy
and so I saw that's diffraction barrier
that's the only important problem that
has been left over that people have saw
that it would not be beatable you cannot
do anything about that you have to
resort it's alright classically if you
want to see the nanoscale and so I got
attracted to this problem and I started
thinking about whether there's really
you know say physics or physical
chemistry or chemistry to sort out the
problem and eventually I realized that
it must be a way by playing with the
molecules trying to turn the molecules
on and off allows you to see adjacent
things that you couldn't see before
thank you do we have some other
questions - professor hell
congratulations thank you my name is
Jonah Rosen from a Swedish popular
science magazine for king of drum stick
right how big was the challenge to put
the molecules on the knot it is of
course something that you have to
realize first you have to realize that
there are methods of turning molecules
on and off now I realized and this was
explained by Professor months and back
that you can turn molecules off by a
phenomenon called stimulated emission
that's a very very basic phenomenon you
wouldn't learn about that in the first
year and after I realized that you can
turn it on and off with stimulated
emission I I knew that there are also
other mechanisms for too many molecules
on and off that are we've all described
in the literature for example
pumping things so long live dark state
sources trans isomerisation and so on
and so there are many many ways of
playing the same game and this turned
out to be of course very very successful
so it's now a whole field and you can
you can play it in this concept in many
many ways
[Music]
I mean the community wasn't very
receptive to the idea of overcoming the
diffraction barrier because people
believe this barrier has been around
since 1873 and and the resolution is
what it is
and and and doing something about it is
if pardon me kind of crazy and not not
not very realistic to do but realize
that you do not have the diffraction
barrier just by trying to change the
waves of light but by playing with the
molecules changing the states of the
molecules I knew that this is going to
work because I couldn't find a various a
physical chemistry reason why it would
not work out so confident and and kept
on going despite all the issues and
problems that came up in the interim
okay thank you
another question is well over there
sufficient access some freelance 4chan
radio and also a green post I think you
congratulations
and you sound still very calm actually
so did you expect you win the prize how
did you feel when you're surprised I
couldn't believe it but fortunately I
remembered the voice of a new mark
this is real and and what they took mr.
took me a while to realize it remotely
okay thank you very very much professor
hell and we are looking forward to meet
again in December for the Nobel Prize
ceremony and our warmest congratulations
thank you so know I turned to you do you
have any other questions or further
questions to to to our experts that
thing's not grounds for who stood up
lasting em used to replace thing in
cambly know about a grand some English
yes the question was is there any limit
that is still valid for the resolution
you can get and the answer is
essentially there is no strict physical
limit limit left however if you want to
have a very high resolution image of an
organelle by fluorescence labels
you must have labeled it properly as you
have labels everywhere essentially and
so there may be practical limit but it's
much much lower than the limit that was
set by Abdur or understood by AB 1873
since 6 1876 it was described yeah and
it was so well believed this limit this
is why Stefan l said you know I almost
gave up because he was up against a
physical limit and most people who are
up against a physical limit do not
survive professionally ok
any further questions if not a
I thank you all for your attention and
we hope to see you back again on Monday
the 13th of October when we will present
this various Riksbank prize in Economic
Sciences in memory of Alfred Nobel for
2014 thank you very much and thank you
for coming